cassia by psychobabble I won't mention
right on now I get to take over the city
if we're gonna get a cash flow going
business because the chance to sell to
us okay that's crazy
okay
and that [ __ ] now what would you like
this cake I had a lot this stuffed out
go in a friendly fire yep best thing is
owning it gives us a discount I like the
sound of that find a sex I think we
already own friendly fire though
they gotta how like everything in the
city business
I mean that's what I am a minute past
time
oh [ __ ]
acquire the sextile okay I really want
to know
Oh a little hobby of mine what the [ __ ]
I don't mean like that they collect the
ball you're supposed to try and find
them all right I'm not even going I've
seen morning star all over the city
doing deals the [ __ ] maybe they'll think
twice about coming back stayed in the
box in apartment good we already have a
new place a brick and mortar baby real
estate is cheap so people are paying us
and not the syndicate good thinking [ __ ]
okay you know I have to say I love
chicken but I don't nee chicken just
like ltos father [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] it's getting [ __ ] I'll lat
yeah let me do that again you know any
other spots
okay let's go baby oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I get
out of here I don't like this
yeah
at the centroid
a lot of hot [ __ ] here but I thought
Kelly
it's the marketing can't understand why
can't do friendly fire that should get
them to back off
why would they be afraid of friendly
fire cuz we own so we got boards
protecting any place the saints own
should be able to take the heat off you
but is that my buddy or is that like a
random
I guess I'll find out shall we I guess
I'll find out
[ __ ] choppers
okay which I get that we're trying to
lose in RIT but this guy's shooting a
[ __ ] I was out the back while we're
speeding down the highway I don't know
if that's the best like course of action
I can find that's all I gotta say
okay you just clear these guys out okay
I guess I'm hiding okay good good good
tips out for Harambee